hello, how are you, andrés gonzález,
with your informative brief for monday
, august 23, the
las vegas metropolitan police department opened its
new interactive kiosk with the
community located on the strip this
is next to resorts world the
goal of this kiosk  is to allow the
department to connect with locals
and tourists directly in addition to
responding to crimes it can also be
accessible to find directions and
answer any questions
and more problems are reported from the
stadium fans were
angry over the weekend
thousands of people attended the
summerslam which  it was held last saturday
however they could not make use
of the food or drink machines the
company that controls the
computerized payments on a
nationwide outage the service could not be
enabled until later in the evening
and today is the first  class day for
universities and colleges around
nevada last week  ada the
board of health voted to approve the
mandatory vaccine for students
within the
university education system students must
meet this requirement
by november 1 if they wish to
register for courses in the spring
there are few exceptions to the rule
and now we move on to  see the weather forecast
we will have a sunny day where we will
reach a temperature of 102
degrees by today tomorrow there is an
air quality alert again due to the
wildfires in california that will
reach southern nevada by tomorrow and
will burn possibly until
wednesday thursday  Have a nice day
andrés gonzález greets you and this was
about the iu news now news in
Spanish
[Music]